what's your go-to
karaoke song
i was a lonely man with empty arms to
fill
trying to find a piece of happiness to
call
i can't do that one this is unilad so
everyone has to leave because the
thing's called alone i'm gonna stay in
here for 10 minutes
by myself and everyone's leaving now
wait hold on guys wait back up i want to
shoot you leaving hold on so everybody
sees you leaving go all right so here
you go everyone's
there everyone's leaving and they're
getting out now
and i am officially when that door
closes
alone
ooh that was the sound okay
i'm alone does this go here
all right
okay
so we're unilad this is a cool thing i
like this i'm excited
uh to do this
i'm alone in the room and they're going
to leave me here for 10 minutes
and i have prompt questions
so these are questions that are prompts
um but
i think the first thing is you got oh
geez
um this is the room that we're in it's
like an interview room
at wimbledon
and we're at wimbledon because of king
richard uh
this is good
all right what happens when
all right here we go here's a camera
what happens when a camera shoots down
the lens of a camera i have no idea what
that's going to look like
when you cut from shot to shot what that
looks like it's probably nothing
there's probably nothing creative about
that since i'm a filmmaker
i'm feeling obligated
to do something creative but i can't
think of anything
all right
[Music]
here's a prompt
who had the most influence on your early
career um
i think
uh
eddie murphy
in in terms of who i wanted to be like
and what i wanted to do eddie murphy was
a really important influence
for me
um
i wanted to be star wars was my favorite
movie and uh eddie murphy
was my oh damn my favorite actor
and
i wanted to be eddie murphy in star wars
um
what's your most favorite
character
you played
um
i've enjoyed a lot of my characters it's
hard to beat mike lowry i think mike
lowry
was my favorite you know miami
in a um
you know fast cars and
guns and stuff like that
um
mike lowry was the fun what's your
biggest achievement
to date
my biggest achievement to date
um
um
the the sustaining and maintenance of my
family i think is the biggest
of to date
um
what's your go-to
karaoke song
i was a lonely man with empty arms to
fill
trying to find a piece of happiness to
call my own
and life is worth living again
then you came in
and then
it says
on them
the rain is gone and the skies were blue
and oh what a revelation
to see
[Music]
someone was saying i
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i can't do that one
i can't hit that that note
um
if you could invite one person into the
room right now dead or alive who would
it be
wow yes
um
nelson mandela
um
i had an experience with with nelson
mandela
where he he asked me to come spend some
time with him
he asked me to come stay with him
and he said he wanted to
you know we were doing an interview one
time and he had us he had this
interesting smile on his face and i was
asking him what's that smile
and
he said if you'll come spend some time
with me i'll teach you
and
i never took him up on it i talked about
that in my book too i never took him up
on it and
you know now that i've sort of begun at
my spiritual journey in my life i
realized he was going to drop some
science on me he was going to give me
some real jewels and i guess i didn't
feel worthy
he's come to me in a in dreams a couple
times
but yes it would be
nelson mandela i would love for i would
love to spend some time with madiba
um
um
rank these rank these in order
rank these in order
um
oh this is that's interesting like rank
these in order
all right it says acting
rank these in order acting
um
acting this is good acting dancing
rapping rank these in order acting
dancing rapping
um
i think i like
um
i think i like acting
the best
oh wow that's on my
that's all my masculinity hold on i
gotta back out of that
acting
dancing rapping
um
i think i'm the best at acting i'm
really the best at acting
um
i enjoy rapping the most there's nothing
like being on stage with a hit record i
love that
um
uh
and i'm not really a good dancer
i'm not a good i mean i can i can learn
if i have to but this is my you know
that's my only move
that's all i can do
i do that over and over do that
so that's it that's all i do in terms of
dancing
so i rank those in order uh
what's the worst thing about being
famous
um
people feel entitled
to
your time and attention
uh people feel like
you know once they
buy your movie or you know once they buy
your music or
your
uh
they they feel like you owe them
and
i don't feel that
um
if i'm eating just mind your business
just stay out stay out my business if
i'm if i'm at a restaurant and if i'm
eating but people do feel like
you owe them
and i think that that can be hard
sometimes
it says tell us
uh your best dad joke
oh damn that was 10 minutes already
that was 10 minutes already
all right so wait all right so we're in
the last one so now you can hear so
this is the producer this is the
producer
this is the producer tell me your name
again i'm becky that's becky becky's the
producer okay so becky the last one i'm
on it says tell me your best dad joke
here come into the light becky says tell
your best dad joke so becky's here all
right
um
so
a guy gets divorced
and
he's he's
hurt and he's walking along the beach
this this was for aladdin i had this
joke and he finds a
lamp
and he picks up the lamp and he rubs the
lamp
and
the guy the genie comes out and he says
you have three wishes and the guy was
like oh my goodness this is perfect
timing i was at the lowest point about
to get
you know i'm just divorced it's terrible
and the genie said but there's only one
one uh caveat here you can make your
wish but whatever you wish for your
ex-wife gets double
and he was like
and he was like you know what if i get
what i want that's all that matters so
first thing he wishes i want a billion
dollars okay and genie gave boom a
billion dollars there he's like oh this
is fantastic it's wonderful and he said
wait a second
did my ex-wife just get two billion
dollars
and the genie said well yeah you know
that that's how it works but you got
your billion he's like
okay okay you know what all right fine
you know i want i want a house in the in
the in the
french riviera that looks out over the
water i want the most beautiful place
boom right there french riviera oh this
is fantastic
wait
did my ex-wife just get two houses on
the french riviera it's like yeah you
know that's kind of how it works
and the dude is walking around his last
wish his last wishes last wish and he
came figured out and he says
can you scare me
half to death
[Laughter]
all right we're out thank you thank you
all right
all right okay
thank you so much becky absolute
pleasure
yes
thank you thank you this is snack wars
xl integrity is important here guys
okay okay meaning meaning when you taste
it yeah you have to be honest that the
american is better oh that's sort of
integrity
american integrity
all right let's go let's see what's in
here
whoa